Inflation is the overall rise in prices of goods and services in an economy.
Here's Claire.
Claire heads over to the corner store to buy a pack of gum.
That pack of gum cost Claire one dollar.
Fast-forward a year and Claire heads to the exact same corner store...
...and buys the exact same pack of gum.
This time though, the pack of gum cost Claire one dollar and two cents.
That two percent rise in the price of the gum is inflation.
Inflation causes a rise in prices and also causes the value of your money,...
...known as purchasing power, to decrease.
Claire's one dollar is worth less today than it did last year.
In general, the demand for goods and services in an economy...
...is greater than the supply, causing prices to rise and therefore inflation.